dieses Beet liefert uns 100 Gläser Pesto
in einem Sommer kein Witz so ein gutes
Basilikum ja hatten wir glaube ich noch
nie die Blätter sind einfach fast so
groß wie meine Hand wir beenden die
Pflanzen immer so dass sie wieder
austreiben können oberhalb der Seiten
Triebe so dass sie sich immer weiter
verzweigen und wir alle vier Wochen
ernten können schaut mal wie viel bei
einem einzigen Ernte Durchgang
zusammenkommt in der Stängel bekommt man
mit dem Pürierstab klein aber ganz dicke
Stengel Seiten nicht mit ins Pesto
wandern bei den zupfe ich die Blätter
einfach ab dann kommen alle Zutaten die
ich euch hier einblende in einen Topf
und wir pürieren das Ganze wenn ihr das
Pesto in Gläser füllt dann solltet ihr
zwei Dinge beachten nehmt keine zu
großen Gläser sonst wird es später
schlecht wenn ihr es nach dem Auftauen
nicht sofort verbraucht und lasst noch
etwas Luft im Glas sonst können die
Gläser beim Einfrieren platzen wir haben
eine vegane Variante mit Parmesan und
eine ohne gemacht und ab ins Gefrierfach
damit da hält sich das Pesto ungefähr
ein Jahr